if you are not happy right now you have
to break your patterns and you have to
look at life from a different
perspective you have to find a different
angle to look at it from because the
[ __ ] goes fast even though it's long
welcome to the Philippines sir thank you
my friend Pia so what's the story you
born in San Fran I was born in San
Francisco went to school and I wanted to
play I mean that's a very bay area kids
dream is to be a basketball star in the
NBA and I was like my girls they were
tall right now I just realized I wasn't
good enough so I was like maybe when
when when I was in college okay I
couldn't even get into college it was
like a Community College yeah San
Francisco I could have been basketball
yep so I was like yeah I think I'll just
go to the Philippines and try to maybe
philippine basketball and it's time to
give up so yeah I got into acting I
started auditioning girlfriend style
yeah different
companies of our products and yeah I
didn't I didn't land any commercials for
like six months I was going to but
literally I know exactly why they're
successful because all you had was you
know adversity coming up I was I just
kept like getting shut down did you like
it or hate it yeah I don't like
rejection did you respect it or were you
like this [ __ ] like people don't see
it like did you respect it where you
were like okay uh I gotta keep working
my craft or you were like to some
[ __ ] that cast somebody it that's
the first one I was like yeah I gotta
keep on okay that's good I mean it's
good that I had kind of had my uh my mom
pushing me she was like yeah I mean just
do whatever you want to do there's gonna
be a lot of failures along the way but
yeah or just keep on failing and you'll
make it eventually and then what
happened and then finally it landed like
this big role there's like small a
really small role on TV so there's only
two to three networks here yeah so I got
one I got in a station and they're like
yeah I'll hop on you'll you'll play a
role and I guess like people just
started catching up and they started
seeing me and that's how basically it
started they're like
his name CN and we'll start getting him
for projects and that's how it started
started through movies and stuff it's
amazing to work my way up from there
what was the biggest was there a break
or was there a single thing that cut or
was it just all Stefan said there was
this one movie that they tried to it was
me and this my partner my own screen
partner
her name is Kim so we did a romantic
comedy movie yeah and it was like number
one in like back in 2013 and that's
honestly like 300 million so whether
they get how okay cool let's make
another one Smee another one so yeah
that's how that's how it's like the big
break right there movies yep and so
what's been done in the last couple
years last couple of years I'm like good
I've been watching your videos man that
[ __ ] inspired me so much
Thank You Man not really like I don't
know I've been pretty confused with what
I want to do like of course I'm I love
what I'm doing I love acting I love
doing all these things but you know
there's like a part of me that just
wants to grow like what you're saying in
your videos that the internet platforms
that you want to just keep on creating
right so you can be global
so I want to do that I want to do that
way it's really hard that's really hard
the good news is so was getting you know
to the point where you got like all that
rejection like the best part is like
when I hear you go through your
narrative I'm like okay good heat like
now that's why I asked a couple nuanced
questions on like how did you deal with
the rejection like how much do you like
the rejection like and you know the
toughest part is when you're coming from
a low spot you know climbing or
rejections a little bit different coming
from a luxurious spot like success they
come from and putting in patience again
kind of sucks and by the way I did it
I'd won in the wine business and I
started all over and then I you know I
won in in in kind of like the online
content thing then I started all over I
would transition from wine content to
then business content and then even took
another step 18 months ago it was like
kind of WebP are committed and
vaynermedia same thing small now it's
getting big and honestly I can already
sense like okay you know four or five
six years from now and it's like a
billion-dollar company I'm gonna be like
alright I gotta go start from to me
it's either either love the process or
you don't like if it's like if you want
something big if you want to grow I mean
you've already pulled off something that
most people never pull off right if you
want to pull off something bigger
that's just more moet normal I mean
that's like the question in my head
right now there is no normal there's you
write like normalizing from other
people's experiences aren't gonna bring
you any value there's no normal there's
you right look and there can't be normal
was it normal 20 years ago to have two
men filming this exactly three it's
super not [ __ ] normal you know you
know like vans are gonna have to get
bigger run out of seats around here like
you know so I think that I think the
biggest thing that you need to think
about is don't quantify based on other
people's feelings like other people
going through this for all human
behaviors are somewhat at some level to
your question normalized there's fear
there's there's anxieties there's
excitement there's confidence there's
insecure there's a million different
things I think the thing that's
interesting about you is you're clearly
driven like
you know first wanted to be in the FDA
and he wanted to be and then he wanted
to be in the PBA then you wanted to act
like I think I think the thing that you
need to understand is that you've got a
gear of motivation that makes you do the
first two things in sports didn't work
out the thing that worked out in acting
it did work out whatever the definition
of what you're trying to figure out
right now it may or may not work what
I'm excited about is the fact that
you've got a gear that makes you want to
do exactly that
I mean I'm falling into that trap though
but I saw your video which was really
helpful a couple of days ago where you
like stop comparing yourself to others
like you who are you comparing yourself
to like the rock no I mean that like the
rock you like I mean like you guys like
like I see you I support like the big
vloggers that have big vloggers and
they're like yeah look but look at me
right I'm not growing all that
aggressively on YouTube my views per
episode are down probably a year over a
year I I'm just not worried about it
because I know why I'm doing it why I
want to do it and I think one of the
biggest problems right now especially
for people under 30 who want to be
influencers or entrepreneurs which is
almost everybody there's a lot of vanity
metrics that they're trying to achieve
to that mean nothing
I raised 50 million dollars so you might
go out of business I've got a million
subscribers so I've got ten million
subscribers so I think I think right now
you know we live in a world that has so
much data that people are living towards
the numbers how many likes how many
followers how much capital have raised
it it's a it becomes a numbers racket
race and it usually leads to bad
behavior because when you're chasing a
number that people can see you often
take shortcuts
I think that's that's the problem like
I'm have to worry now like do they like
logan paul has nothing to do with you
that's true that's true
it just doesn't Logan's gonna do Logan
you're gonna do you like I'm gonna me
and Russia's gonna do her like it's it's
great to be inspired by it's great to be
inspired by it's great to have use
something as like a North Star for
ambition but that needs to be manifested
in a positive way not a negative way
like because what you're talking about
is actually any
when you're looking at what somebody
else has you're talking about nd mb's
[ __ ]
you know I know I'm at my weakest when I
root for the New York Jets
I envy teams that win a lot of Super
Bowls and it's and I can and I know what
that feeling is that's a weak feeling
I'm weak as a sports fan but as a human
I'm the reverse and that's why I fully
understand and and scary part is most
people are weak as humans they envy and
I'm like get the [ __ ] out of that like I
I get pumped when I when I I'll give you
a good example
this kid dunk that worked for me for a
year when I met him he had this
basketball count dunk I don't know if
you follow because you like basketball
like here like 2 million followers I
didn't I wasn't jealous of him or being
like this kid I was inspired I was like
good for you [ __ ] like you [ __ ]
like are doing what I believe in and I'm
no question that was like a match of
like okay like I want to cook I want it
not that I wanted to compete with it cuz
I he's like a he's like a child of mine
let alone little brother 19 but but you
know it's going to be inspired by
but being envious up and it's a very
very fine line and I understand but it
usually speaks with being its happy
inside and I think the bigger thing that
you need to think about is do you love
your process like are you enjoying like
is this fun and I'm sure he's a lovely
dude is this fun that you're filming
this or are you doing it because you
think it's gonna get you to the next
level of success and I think that that's
an important thing to understand for me
both but if I didn't love it then
[ __ ] there's a lot of things I know I
should be doing
I should be answering unlimited
questions on Quora
I just don't want to know some not I
want to hire a writer to get that done
because it's a good idea to the fun fact
for everybody out there you know I
should be commenting more now with
threaded comments on Instagram so I show
up at the top because I'm verified and
get tons of audience
I'm just how it works I'm a big believer
that one of the if you are fortunate
enough to be verified right now on
Instagram you should be replying on
other verified accounts at scale but not
spammy not just like yo or a peach emoji
if somebody's got a cute butt like you
should be replying with something
meaningful because when people see it's
kind of like this I tweeted about last
night in in Singapore about if you do
the follow unfollow thing you're lame
not because it may not work or work or
it's because the intent is not good you
follow somebody hoping they follow you
back and then you unfollow them totally
it's posturing it's got the wrong intent
but if you go and leave comments of
everybody and you actually follow people
and become part of their communities
like intent matters and so anyway
there's a ton of things I know I should
be doing but I don't do them because
they're not necessarily the thing I love
to do and I think only when you love it
is when it really gets cracking I didn't
make a lot of content do a podcast all
this other stuff because what I was
loving right there was super head-down
Vayner for three years Vayner got big
enough and I got better I got better and
I figured out a system I'm still living
my business life d-rush was filling it
which is why I wasn't a vlogger the way
that everybody else grew up which was
this right yeah right this was this was
Casey this was Logan this was you know
everybody else hiding roll that out
because if I was doing that I wouldn't
have been able to do my life that's how
I came up with this
got it this was unique and maybe even
douchey and awkward and definitely
socially not accepted three years ago do
you have your camera this is su super
super socially awkward three years ago
and now and that was kind of accepted
right people are like okay cool he's
watch and that's that so I think what
you need to think about is a very big
reason acting probably looked out was
you both thought it could bring you
something you were looking for from a
level of attention and success and fame
and dollars but you also liked it
because otherwise if you didn't like it
you would have quit after the third no
at officience
when you do something for money you quit
when you do it because you love it you
do it forever hundred percent people
quit all the time because they're doing
it for the money cryptocurrency real
estate tech investing it's all because
whatever's a hot market all those
markets go up and down they go up and
down from the reasons they are they
create big bubbles is because an
enormous amount of people are in it for
the money for the money not for the
investment for I want money to do
something with that money I think the
bigger question is what do you want the
money for I have a question yeah in
terms of structure right am I supposed
to have my own structure or is that just
what does that mean like am I supposed
to be you tell my agents production
companies all that no I mean no like in
terms of how I put all my videos am I
supposed to have like a schedule and I
said supposed to I say um look I think
you have to respect an audience I do
think a schedule time is something
people enjoy ish I don't but I think I
think you can win either way I mean are
you asking noon every day or are you
asking do it every day or like what
kind of like that like am I supposed to
be you're supposed to do nothing so like
you've got understand an audience is
gonna react a certain way but let me say
this if you tell me what when I hear
that question I'm like I don't want him
to have a schedule because the fact that
you're even asking it means it's a
stress point for you right so to me if
you think if I said to you if somebody
who you admire advice and I said you
give through five days a week at noon
it's probably not going to succeed
because the pressure or the anxiety of
having to do that when it doesn't come
natural or interesting to you breaks it
down if I said to you create and put out
when you have things that you're
inspired by or you're feeling it well
then you've got something it's all an
inside game I think the bigger question
is like what do you up to like why are
you doing it like what's up you know
like you have to ask that because it's
is it is it blocking and insecurities
have to get the girl is it is it is
because you're trying to amass as much
as you can because you don't actually
don't like working and you want to live
it the reason so many people say bail in
life and business is their model is let
me get the money so that I can enjoy and
relax they think of it as like hoarding
it and then eating it all over time so
our retirement and also it's such a bad
way to think because then you're feeling
the pressure of like massing so that you
can then enjoy you need to be enjoying
the amassing so much that you never get
to the enjoying part like I will never
retire
cuz it's not as fun as working like it's
not as fun like it's very it's not as
fun for me to lay on the beach and play
golf all day and and and lay on a yacht
in the middle of the Mediterranean for a
hundred days in the summer and go to
vineyards and go to concerts and and see
friends that's not as fun as [ __ ] 15
hours of meetings all day that is what
people have to figure out whether that's
singing or being a mother or teaching a
classroom what is more fun than the
cliche things that everybody puts in
their instrument I don't want to lay in
a swan in a pool I don't want to I don't
want to go to Ibiza for four days I do
not want to I don't I want to sit there
and smile I'm literally the reverse
human people go in there feeds and they
have FOMO because everybody's in Ibiza
and swans I'm smiling because I'm like
you're an Ibiza
but also we shouldn't do you understand
Raisa because if you're in Ibiza and I'm
putting in work my machines getting big
and like I to me the game matters and by
like somebody maybe looking and being
like Gary looks like [ __ ] 4 a.m. six
flights and Asia and I'm sitting here in
Ibiza and for her or him that's winning
and that's great figure out what your
[ __ ] winning is my winning is
different than a lot of people's I don't
get envy I get excited I get competitive
I enjoy it I join my thing what's your
thing that makes you the happiest they
just focus they're only there you gotta
ask why what are you chasing yeah maybe
what's happening to me now is
I'm looking at all these accounts 100%
should I be doing this yep like that on
my damn should I be
well you're realizing your culture and
you know is that the attention is going
away from the movie theater and the
television and going into the phone and
these platforms that's true so you you
can feel that you won something and now
it's going away
yes exactly exactly brother I know what
the score is I know what the score is
but but I think you need to not look at
that as a negative you need to look at
that as a positive because if you were
an actor from 25 years ago you would
have just become complacent you're lucky
that the game's forcing you to have to
be sharp again
either you look at it as a positive or
negative people would say oh this is a
negative you're losing your throne I'm
saying no no this is awesome you get to
keep playing that's somebody who loves
the game
got it I think I sandbag myself from
success
I could have way more success but I'm
trying to I'm for playing my life well
everybody's playing for night I'm
playing for play of my life of my career
I mean I'm slow rolling it like I'm for
playing it like I'm holding off for more
enjoyment later you know I mean that's
lit but I honestly genuinely believe
that that's what I'm doing with my
career like I listen the rock will tell
you like I came off a vacation I said
you know what I'm holding off too much
let me get a little more offensive and I
said I'm gonna fix Instagram I'm gonna
fix my podcast and I'm gonna get into
hip-hop 20 months later I'm doing just
okay from you know like so I can turn it
on and off which is cool and that's
talent and that feels nice but but it
speaks to me liking and I think you need
to you need to find something you love
you're also doing sports yes
AJ and I my brothers started a sports
representation business Vayner sports
repping NFL athletes jerry maguire stuff
so it's super fun we'll get into the NBA
- any sports those are kind of like
places we're looking at so I'm excited
about that so you came here when you
were held like 1819 and now your hell
turned 29 three days ago good man
two days ago waitlet Liz they sorta same
birthdays my sister
Syrians Kent Syrians we are we're loving
people very sensitive wait you're
speaking here I didn't wall of Asia
I have no [ __ ] idea Steve now this is
like one of my one of my dreams to be
like an inspirational speaker like what
you're doing right now like you like the
live stage yes and at the same time I
want to be able to kiss like right now I
have like most of my followings are like
old people and kids
yep yeah that so yeah you have 40 year
old moms and little kids little kids
because of the movies you've been doing
yeah yeah yep yes so like right now like
a couple like maybe last year I was like
and I want to be like an inspirational
speaker you know I kiss all the kids
sometimes when I when I do meet and
greets they're like yeah what should i
do love like they're asking me for
advice I'm like man one of these days I
should be I want to talk about the
things I like what you're doing yeah
I want to be able to give out advice
I've got really I generally think
anybody can do it what I mean by that is
you can start tomorrow the biggest
problem is the way people think of
inspirational speakers now unfortunately
people are pulling putting up the sides
the the definition to me the definition
of somebody's an inspirational
communicator is the person that speaks
the most truth you can do it tomorrow
you're famous in this country if you go
talk about your insecurities your
strengths and your weaknesses you'll be
off to the races people don't even hear
me talking about my weaknesses do it all
the time now second school I say this
another that I can't just say like they
don't think it matters because I've
achieved success but there are things
that other people do well on you have a
fear I'm getting at is I don't agree
that's why I'm giving you a divisive
don't try to be this just go talk be
like here's my story and then what you
start happening is you learn over time
like it took me a while to talk about
the fact that I didn't own any of Wine
Library that was something I kept inside
but as I got to tell that that opened up
doors for other people I thought it kind
of potentially looked bad on my dad and
then I kind of looked at it differently
I mean that's what a migrant families do
then I opened up now now when I tell
kids to be patient now they're like wait
a minute he really started with nothing
at 34 yeah I mean I mean I built I
started you to the 30 I started business
YouTube at 34 the wine I was 31 but like
that but that business was my dad's like
I wasn't getting the money so you know I
think that um yeah I mean it's about
patient like 29 literally 29 year old me
or 13 years ago it's just a
fundamentally a different person it was
still me right I put out a video the
other day from 2008
and everyone's like Jesus it's basically
the same [ __ ] and it is which is amazing
but there's so much experience there's
so much more perspective there's under
different understandings and and
speaking has allowed me to get to it
like there's nothing more honest than
you and a audience especially when it's
just you oh yeah you know I'm not I'm
not in Broadway plays like this is just
me one-man show straight on the dome you
know I don't even I don't have
powerpoints or other things to hide
behind like I really genuinely don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna say when I
go onstage I mean and you see it like
knows it's like it goes in patterns like
I'll get into it I'll get into a pattern
I'll get into like a subject matter like
this whole trip is now about parenting
all of a sudden you know like tell your
truth man
like honestly your weakness is
predicated on your secrets and your and
your and your strengths are predicated
your truths it's very real it's gonna
last 20 minutes not for sure man I
really uh I you know what I like how how
you're reacting to my commentary like
like you're you're gonna win dude like I
poked and you didn't run away or you
said yeah yeah yeah it's so like
listenmi listenmi I mean this very very
very seriously on your truths expose
your secrets you'll you'll you'll be cut
you'll become a hundred percent
unstoppable
billion-dollar advice right there I
think your mother just finished up the
meeting obviously took a shower and
changed a little bit on this whirlwind
Asian tour and I think the the
interesting thing is literally as I'm as
I'm trying to put a a bumper here as a
bumper how does it a Linda one [ __ ]
no nonetheless somebody there's a debate
right now going on Twitter of like how
many years do you have to work until the
hard work and to the thing this guy's
like Gary you said you hustled your face
off for ten years he's like I only had
to do it for two years I couldn't
imagine doing it for ten and I'm
laughing at him and another guy jumps in
and goes well Gary said it best
eat [ __ ] for blank ears and eat caviar
for the rest of your life and one of the
things I'm realizing especially off the
talk would just had is for me the [ __ ]
is the caviar like I love the [ __ ]
process I love building like and you
just have to be self-aware or like if
you want if for you life is spending 30
40 50 years on a beach with mansions and
playing tennis all day and golf and
that's amazing and then I assume if
that's your great happiness you are
gonna try to make as much wealth as
possible as quickly as possible because
you think or you know that that's what
makes you happy I just I'm just really
really interested in starting to get
this conversation into a happiness
conversation like I just think a lot of
people are trying to achieve success and
use fame or money as makeup for a
situation that they're just not happy
about like you have to figure out how to
make your day in and day out happy like
otherwise you're gonna be impatient and
try to be out of it as quickly as
possible to buy those things or you're
gonna regret it later in life right I
think people that are workaholics that
regret missing their family is it didn't
make them as happy as they thought they
didn't take advantage of the family time
that like it's just it's this is just a
big happiness game one big [ __ ]
happiness game and that young man has
achieved a lot of 29 and I'm just I'm
asking him
like you know cuz he has under a million
followers on Instagram and he must have
2 million - what to keep up with the
Joneses the Jones has been brought up a
bunch of this trip to me in my head
conversations on and off screen and like
I just want to find these Joneses I want
to find these Joneses and kill them
because the [ __ ] Joneses are [ __ ]
you guys up I don't know who these
[ __ ] Joneses are but they're bad
[ __ ] people the Joneses are bad bad
people
and they're and they're ruining most of
your lives and I just don't give a [ __ ]
about the Joneses I don't know these
Joneses are and they definitely don't
have any impact on my [ __ ] life and
so I figure out what makes me happy and
so like that's what I do and you need to
figure out what that is and and I just I
just don't understand how people think
wealth is the gateway to happiness
I just don't or you know the gateway the
happiness is to love your process
whatever that may be whether that's
creates wealth or doesn't if that
creates legacy and art or doesn't that
creates impact in the world or it
doesn't you've got it you've got to try
and figure that out at all costs and if
you're not happy right now you need to
do something different
you just have to if you are not happy
right now you have to break your
patterns and you have to look at life
from a different perspective you have to
find a different angle to look at it
from because this [ __ ] goes fast even
though it's long pull 30 years white
shaved off the face boy one more victory
blood sweat and tears point warning
doing standpoint stain kind of care boy
the repercussions so discussed